Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Andrea Giglio
Bentrovati.
Potenza e fragilità .
Qualcuno di voi si domanderà
che cosa hanno a che fare
queste due parole
apparentemente così lontane.
Be’, dovete sapere
che fino a qualche tempo fa
le mie due figlie più grandi,
Marta e Francesca,
per addormentarsi
sceglievano due parole e io,
su quelle due parole,
dovevo raccontare una storia.
Ora questa cosa non me la chiedono più,
perché loro sono diventate grandi,
ma io no.
E quindi la storia la vorrei
raccontare a voi questa sera.
Allora, la storia inizia
con il solito bambino,
ricciolino, vivace, ma intrappolato
da un terribile incantesimo:
le parole facevano fatica ad uscire,
proprio rimanevano bloccate
nella sua bocca.
Comunque passano gli anni,
il bambino diventa un ragazzo
però ci soffre molto, moltissimo
su questo problema delle balbuzie,
tant’è che prova ad incontrare
psicologi, logopedisti
- tutti bravissime persone,
bravissimi professionisti -
ma nessuno riesce a sciogliere
questo incantesimo.
Un giorno fa un viaggio a Roma e così,
per pura fortuna, incontra una vecchietta.
Si chiamava Teresa… di Calcutta,
e questa vecchietta dice al ragazzo:
“Quando un giorno aspetterai un figlio,
qualsiasi cosa succeda, non avere paura!”
Tant'è che tutti intorno dissero:
“Ah Madre Teresa,
ma che belle parole di libertà!”
Invece il ragazzo pensò:
“Io non sono interessato
a queste parole in libertà!
Io voglio libertà per le mie parole!”
Comunque, passarono ancora degli anni
e il sogno di questo ragazzo
era di diventare un attore comico.
Invece diventò un ingegnere informatico.
(Risate)
Perché era molto più semplice
digitare le parole davanti ad un computer,
che recitare parole
davanti ad un pubblico.
Ma un bel giorno,
nella piazza del suo paese,
stavano allestendo una grande festa
con un palcoscenico e un microfono
proprio lì, nel mezzo.
Ora, voi potete immaginare cosa significa
un microfono per un attore comico,
ma immaginate anche cosa significa
un microfono per un balbuziente.
Ma il desiderio di questo ragazzo
di provare le battute che aveva scritto,
le battute comiche,
era troppo grande e non ci pensò.
Salì i gradini del palcoscenico,
prese il microfono e disse:
“Ehm, salve a tutti!
Sono un ingegnere informatico.
Pensate che sono così bravo in Internet
che le mie prime parole, appena nato,
sono state: UEB, UEB, UEB!”
(Risate)
Successe proprio così.
Le persone ridevano e lui era felice
perché le parole uscivano
fluide nell'aria.
Era successa una magia.
Era successo un qualcosa di eccezionale.
Ma la cosa più bella, che questo ragazzo
apprezzava in quel momento,
era che le persone non ridevano più
di lui, ma ridevano con lui.
Ecco, a questo punto una delle mie figlie
mi avrebbe interrotto e avrebbe detto:
“Sì papà, abbiamo capito che sei te!
(Risate)
E poi comunque ti sei dimenticato…
… hai parlato della fragilità,
ma ti sei dimenticato
di dire della potenza.
Allora io direi:
“Sì ragazze, questo è un po’ il problema…
… di avere il papà egocentrico,
direbbe la mamma!
(Risate)
Ma alla potenza ci arrivo.
Prima però devo dirvi
una cosa importantissima,
perché, quando io parlavo delle mie
disabilità, delle mie debolezze,
succedeva una cosa stranissima:
le persone che avevo davanti sembravano
più disponibili, più gentili…
Insomma tiravano fuori il meglio
di loro stessi.
Cosa? Cosa?
Un attimo!
Io parlo delle mie disabilità
e loro tirano fuori la parte migliore?
E se funzionasse anche al contrario?
È allora che sono diventato
volontario in una casa
che ospita persone con disabilità.
Oh, funzionava!
Funzionava!
Le persone, tutte le persone
che ho incontrato
e che sono diventate parte della mia vita,
hanno tirato fuori e stanno tirando fuori
veramente la parte migliore di me.
E questa cosa è meravigliosa!
Però, come in tutte le storie
che si rispettino,
c'è sempre un momento difficile,
un momento buio.
Perché, credetemi, incontrare
una disabilità può fare un po' paura.
Ma per chi è genitore, o sta diventando
un genitore, generare disabilità…
… be’, quella è la più grande delle
paure!
E allora la scena cambia
e andiamo all’Ospedale Civile di Padova.
Siamo convocati io e mia moglie,
che è incinta.
Una dottoressa ci fa accomodare
in una stanzina piccolissima
con una meravigliosa luce al neon
dove c’era una sola sedia
e fa accomodare mia moglie.
Prende il foglio e legge:
“Trisomia ventuno.”
A quel punto per me il tempo si ferma
e l'unica eco che ho nelle mie orecchie
sono le parole di quella vecchietta
di Calcutta:
“Don’t be afraid! Non avere paura!”
Ma il colpo di genio
ce l’ha mia moglie che dice:
“Mi scusi dottoressa, ma nostro figlio
è un maschio o è una femmina?”
(Risate)
La dottoressa dice:
“Ehm, mi scusi signora,
forse lei non ha ben capito.
Trisomia ventuno è la sindrome di Down!”
Mia moglie risponde:
“No, Dottoressa, ho capito benissimo!
Ma volevo solo sapere se nostro figlio
è un maschio o è una femmina!”
Allora la dottoressa, sempre più spaesata,
cerca: “Ehm… è femmina!”
Allora io a quel punto dico:
“E ma porca miseria!
Non siamo riusciti
neanche questa volta
a fare il maschio!
Daniela, ma insomma!”
(Risate)
Abbiamo dato la sedia
alla dottoressa perché…
(Risate e applausi)
Grazie!
Noi ci scherziamo molto su questa cosa,
ma vi assicuro che è stato, ovviamente,
un momento molto difficile.
Forse il più difficile della nostra vita.
Anche perché, non so se lo avete capito,
ma non siamo dei supereroi!
Comunque dopo pochi mesi è arrivata Anna!
Eccola qua! Ve la presento!
(Applausi)
Che è una meraviglia!
È bellissima ed è anche forte!
Ammetto che il mio è un giudizio
un po' di parte, lo avete capito!
E comunque la cosa più bella
che Anna ha portato nelle nostre famiglie,
la cosa veramente meravigliosa
è che ci ha reso tutti persone migliori:
ha reso migliore me, migliore mia moglie,
le sue sorelle e tutti quelli
che in qualche modo incontriamo.
E se non è potenza questa!
Però abbiamo notato una cosa:
che tutte le persone che incontriamo
sono tutte molto informate
dal punto di vista tecnico
della disabilità,
in particolare della sindrome di Down,
siamo tutti cintura nera di villocentesi,
di analisi, sappiamo tutto.
Ma poche, molto poche di queste persone,
hanno avuto degli incontri
con persone con disabilità.
E allora per mettere insieme
un po’ queste cose
e raccontare la nostra storia,
abbiamo deciso di aprire
una pagina Facebook
che si chiama:
“Buone Notizie Secondo Anna”,
dove così, senza prenderci
troppo sul serio,
ma proprio per niente anzi direi,
raccontiamo le buone notizie
che ci porta Anna.
Per esempio un po' di tempo fa
Francesca è venuta a casa dicendo:
“Lo sapete che usano Down
come un’offesa a scuola?”
E allora abbiamo fatto questa cartolina
dove Anna dice:
“Ma è vero che a volte usate
‘Ma sei Down?’ come fosse un’offesa?
Bella questa! E voi sareste up?”
(Risate)
Oppure un’altra ancora dove dice:
“Ma è vero che dite
‘affetto da sindrome di Down’
e non dite ‘affetto da occhi azzurri’?
Bella questa!
Si dice ‘con sindrome di Down’!”
Perché crediamo che anche le parole
abbiano la loro importanza!
Anche perché, se parliamo
di sindrome di Down,
voi lo sapete, è semplicemente
un cromosoma in più,
una X in più!
Non lo so, vi faccio un esempio:
avete presente il TED?
Aggiungete una piccola X…
(Applausi)
No, perché vi faccio questo esempio?
Perché voi oggi per conoscere il TED,
per parlare con il TED,
parlare con le persone
avete fatto un po' di fatica.
Ecco quindi l'invito è:
fate un po' di fatica e non evitate
gli incontri di disabilità
che avrete nella vostra vita.
Sia personali, ma anche delle persone
che vi stanno intorno.
Una piccolissima raccomandazione però:
in questo percorso ci si può perdere
perché la tendenza nostra
è sempre quella di mettersi
o un gradino sopra o un gradino sotto.
Ecco! Per guardarsi negli occhi
bisogna mettersi allo stesso livello!
E in questo senso, a me
capita spesso di perdermi.
Per questo mi piace,
come un moderno Pollicino,
lasciare dei sassolini
lungo le mie storie.
Bene, l'ho fatto anche questa sera
con questo segno,
che nel linguaggio dei segni
è la parola “disabilità”.
Quindi non mi resta che augurarvi
di cercare tracce di disabilità
nella vostra vita, di accoglierle
e soprattutto ricordate che:
le paure che riuscite a guardare
in faccia, si trasformano in coraggio!
Grazie di cuore davvero!
(Applausi)